thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a sketchy
wild ride with Stevo we've got a guy
who's really really good with sketchy
stuff sketches in particular and man
what a great conversation we have I
might want to apologize in advance for
maybe being a little bit insensitive by
just barraging him with precisely uh the
stuff that I knew he did not want to be
barraged with hey man you know I I'm a
jerk but uh it actually played out
pretty well and um you know it's a great
episode you know what else plays out
really well is uh my experience with my
wiener and uh Bluetooth tablets because
man I love it I can't can't say it
enough when I chew up a Bluetooth tablet
and my tongue's blue and then next thing
you know about a half an hour later I'm
the heart is a rock and boning the hell
out of my girl why well because
Bluetooth tablets contain the same
active ingredient as both Viagra and
Cialis except they only cost a fraction
of the price and what's even crazier is
that you can get an entire month's
supply of Bluetooth tablets absolutely
for free all you got to pay is five
bucks for shipping how do you do that
well you go to bluetooth.com you use the
promo code Stevo and you very quickly
conveniently and easily consult with the
medical provider on the website takes no
time at all it's not awkward or
inconvenient and boom your
prescription's set and your Bluetooth
tablets are in the mail and all you had
to pay was five bucks for shipping
because you got an entire month's Supply
completely for free man what a deal and
again to get this deal you go to
bluetooth.com you use the promo code
Stevo man you're gonna have a great time
because I know that I always do so
without further Ado let's get into it
all right dude we're [ __ ] ready to
rock
are you nervous no no
ladies and gentlemen Shane Gillis yes
yeah dude what's up in the flesh damn
super stoked man I see you on podcasts
and uh huge numbers yeah yeah don't blow
it for us
we'll see
um yeah man so and so you said we met at
Just for Laughs Festival yeah yeah
Montreal yeah well it was briefly we
were on the same like van from the
airport oh God yeah yeah yeah okay I
think so your dog was there I was in the
van too I think that time oh really yeah
hell yeah I didn't leave that much of an
impression though well I mean I was I
was pretty quiet I was in the back I was
excited you were there though dude I
[ __ ] well thanks brother I super
appreciate that man I was uh for anybody
who doesn't know just for laughs is is
not even arguably it's like definitely
the biggest Comedy Festival there is and
for them to uh Embrace Stevo's stand-up
comedy was a major breakthrough for me
oh for real yeah like not everybody
loves it when someone comes from one
Arena of entertainment into stand-up
comedy yeah and uh the like that
to have um just for laughs sign off on
me in that respect they they brought me
to the Vancouver to the Montreal to the
Toronto even to the Mexico one so oh
[ __ ] I feel like I kind of have been
recognized in stand-up comedy for that
reason yeah it's funny that people are
like that like they get us good
comedians are like yeah oh you think you
can just show up it's like yeah yeah
it's [ __ ] stand-up comedy yeah dude
it's open likes you can literally show
up anything you can yeah it's uh you
know there's some pushback but I never
let it stop me I [ __ ] stuck with it
dude yeah I mean well you also made
something that's funnier than stand up
already wow and nothing because you
don't have to say but like nothing's
funnier thanks yeah whatever I uh you
know over the years of Performing
stand-up gradually like my world's just
converged like the stand-up actually
kind of worked its way back to the
jackass stuff because I would for my new
hour go out and do the gnarliest stunts
ever and make the ACT about that and
then after each bit I screen the footage
of the bit that's awesome I love it dude
yeah that's that's great it's it's
really like I've stumbled on this like
fully original approach to to Live
Comedy and I'm stoked on it
be at itself be funny if people copied I
mean I would I would love it but I knew
he was hammering his nuts after a joke
I would love it if they do because
some of this stuff is hard to replicate
though because the the lengths that we
went through to get like oh my god dude
uh we gave him a spinal tap and then we
went for a race
yeah
No One's Gonna that's [ __ ] wild yeah
yeah Dad did some pretty heavy stuff for
it and it's gonna get even heavier for
my next hour really yeah but we don't
even need to worry about that but uh so
Legion of skanks how about that well
that's another podcast yeah yeah I'm on
there are you doing skank Fest I am dude
how about the [ __ ] lineup for a skank
fast that's crazy I gotta believe that
as we're recording this it'll actually
come out
because it's what October 15th 16th yeah
in Vegas someone's gonna [ __ ] die did
they put you out not me I'll be dead
this comes out okay oh nice
um
even your dog throws up
[Laughter]
I don't know dude but uh
Jesus we haven't seen her do this before
yeah
I don't know
I don't know Wendy that was not cool man
maybe we should leave the door open
where would it stinks too
we all just start vomiting on the
podcast Wendy poor girl
um so Legion of skanks is like a comedy
it's
man she ate some [ __ ] that didn't agree
with her dude should we open up that
door so yeah yeah so she can barf all
over the place
yeah after a shaky start you wanna you
wanna just open up the door
yeah yeah so so I'm not liable go up
there you go yeah bye-bye
feel better
yeah they can uh they can bill us for
the carpet cleaning yeah and by the way
we're in New York how about that yeah
yeah
um so uh Legion of skanks has this
Comedy Festival like every comedian in
the [ __ ] world is on it like I saw
their their Instagram post like it's
unfucking belief are they paying you to
go yeah they're paying everybody
together I think so yeah yeah yeah yeah
how many people are expected to go to
this is it like adjusting you know what
you know what it is it's literally like
I think the Gathering of the Juggalos
yeah if they had a a Comedy Festival
Legions Kings fans are Juggalos by the
way yeah they are like you'll see these
dudes and be like yo this is a wild time
right yeah we did Houston last
the last one was in Houston it's been
there's been only been like three years
so far yeah
um
I don't know maybe four or five right it
was only first I'm 34. 34. all right
yeah and uh yeah the first one was I I
did like a spot on the first one like at
the time I was like damn this is huge
like I was so excited yeah it's it's
crazy to me that uh that it's such a
huge festival and has it because
like a legion of skanks it's uh
kind of
what is it it's it's like a super
hardcore
like it's kind of like uh rap music that
that is
like deliberately wants to make sure it
cannot be played on the radio because
it's too gangster you know yeah Legend
of skanks wants to be just too gangster
for mainstream
and that's like like Louis Lewis Jake
Owens yeah like he's leader in skanks
yeah for sure like uh yeah it's Louis
big J and Dave Smith yeah and it's yeah
Big J's and arguably the more uh
like user friendly of of yeah which is
shocking because he's wild yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um so uh so yeah dude we'll be there man
our like you're uh
looking forward to that I am I am it's a
little I'm I'm a little like oh man I'm
gonna be hungover like it's a guarantee
like yeah it's gonna be a rough one from
show to show like and you do still how
many stages are there with that many
five right now it's just all day yeah
yeah it's crazy it'll just be drugs
The Comedy Jam the singing all that [ __ ]
it'll be fun I believe it and then at
night is uh is it gonna be like a rave
kind of a deal yeah there's some of that
yeah it's just dudes though it's like 90
dudes like I don't know dude I think
there's gonna be chicks too a little bit
yeah there's some chicks
um so so where are you living these days
I live in Queens I live in Astoria okay
there we go yeah yeah yeah
and uh you came from Philadelphia yes
originally from Philly yeah I was
actually in Philly today I went down I
did uh the show with Chris Rock last
night wow that's sick that was [ __ ]
crazy uh what were the measures for uh
preventing people from recording this
show what they're saying uh oh they had
he has those the bags the bags yeah yeah
what are the measures from people going
on stage and slapping them there's some
guys back there
they would get [ __ ] up yeah I bet you
that never happens again to him no that
happened uh the dude tried it with
Chappelle yeah like a week later right
right I was like a knife and got [ __ ]
stopped by Jamie Foxx and Buster on his
arms like dislocated it's right into the
ambulance and then like a couple days
after that they're like are the guys
booked for attempted murder for
something completely unrelated like oh
yeah that's right yeah
it's because it's crazy times man it's
crazy you tried to stab Dave's life
he definitely had a knife on him yeah
what's he doing dude that's wild it's a
wild Choice yeah yeah you ever had any
weird hecklers try to [ __ ] with you
um I mean dude Were You There When Big
Jay got no I wasn't trying oh my God
yeah
I saw that and then we were talking to
Louie Gomez about that like because you
see the clip of him running over to kick
him and he missed and it's like I feel
like that would be like a like one of
those dreams where you like punch
somebody and you can't punch
you know like he must think about that
like dude because I you can you know
that guy wants to [ __ ] fight
that's the best part of the clip is
Lewis who's no hesitation like Jake it's
it almost looks like Lewis pushes him
because of how fast he's right behind
like jumping on the stage like no
hesitation for sure yeah because when we
brought it up to on the podcast he's
like dude and I [ __ ] miss dude it's
like he's been waiting his whole life
for that moment he [ __ ] missed dude
yeah we'll get it again we'll get some
more fights I'll do it for sure he gets
in fights dude yeah I uh
we tried those bags on my tour the the
bags
it's just like it just keeps getting
more expensive and more expensive yeah
every time it's like two bucks a bag
right so like I think like whatever yeah
well if you're doing like stadiums it's
like 40 cents a bag but like the smaller
the venue the more you know right and we
and we uh we have
like um people passing out during our
show all the time so one time we had
three people pass out during the show
and somebody's like call 9-1-1
again
like
one person find like you can keep the
show going on while it's happening but
then like there was like three and then
some guy had a [ __ ] seizure what the
[ __ ] because the bits are like really
kind of funny there's a like after every
bit in the show I screen footage of the
business and uh like three of the videos
I play are culprits for making
full-grown men pass out cold in the
audience Jesus and we're so desensitized
by it because people are freaking out
I'm like oh yeah you know like can we
move him out of the show and [ __ ]
keep the show going on like I'm
desensitized to the point where I'm like
dude are you good yet
or there's like uh we had a standing
room only show in like six people passed
out while standing yeah
but it happened so much like uh Steve's
experienced that so much that he's like
he was like so pissed he's like okay you
know what fine watch what's gonna happen
you're going to see the person drop and
then a spread and then a drop and then a
spread and like sure enough I was so
pissed when I found out that it was
going to be standing room only I was
like dude I'm gonna cancel this [ __ ]
show I can't have people passing out on
their feet yeah and then I said you know
what actually we're gonna document the
show to show what a terrible idea it is
so that we'll never have standards what
city was it in that was in New York
Syracuse I think yeah was it hot or is
it just the videos it's like a it's like
there's needles and spines and like
there's that vasectomy there's there's
the the vasectomy Olympics
and then there's the the epidural foot
race damn yeah and then what's the other
one yeah we don't need to give away the
whole food
then there's another one that's even
more upsetting than the so it's always
like uh people that just kind of and
they're out or like they like get really
hot and sweaty and they go to the
bathroom and like sometimes the ushers
can't get in the bathroom because
they're on the floor okay so they can't
open the door because their feet are
blocking it oh [ __ ] so you have to like
the
I have to go do like the you know before
the show like okay security like we do
get people passing out during the show
and they're doing what and I'm just like
yeah that doesn't happen anywhere I know
it's uh it's like it's it's pretty crazy
I've never heard about people passing
out during jackass movies and like it
seems that I have raised the bar yeah
yeah and like it's it's even crazier
when like they get taken away in
stretchers and because I'm like okay
look like you're not I'm not a doctor I
can't tell you yeah yeah yeah but like
it's not as serious as you think it is
but people are just out in a Stretcher
yeah except for the people who hit their
heads because they're walking around
um yeah like I understand everybody's
been perfectly fine we had uh I did I
went to Catholic school and kids would
[ __ ] faint we had to go to church
every week There's No Air Conditioning
it was hot as [ __ ] yeah kids would faint
not and it's Catholic so you're standing
and kneeling standing were you an altar
boy no I wasn't I got out of it oh nice
I got caught in third grade drinking the
wine damn yeah third grade the priest
came in he's like
what are you doing he's like jackpot
yeah
now to be fair drinking is not always a
jackpot but man is it for me every
morning when I wake up and hydrate
myself with a pint of water into which I
pour athletic greens ag1 why is it a
jackpot because it's comprehensive
convenient daily nutrition and it's
delicious and it's loaded with 75
different
vitamins minerals Whole Food sourced
superfoods adaptogens and probiotics
it's great for your gut health for your
mental health and it fills in all of the
gaps in your diet if you're not eating
enough greens and nutrients I mean dude
talk about a jackpot athletic greens
ag-1 is a total jackpot it's absolutely
delicious and what's even better if you
go to athletic greens.com
Stevo then they're going to throw in
with your order uh five comprehensive
packets of daily nutrition
plus an entire gear supply of immune
boosting vitamin D boom you're gonna get
hooked up with that on your first order
if you go to athletic greens.com
Stevo it's a jackpot every morning man I
love it you're gonna love it and use
that athleticgreens.com Devo to support
the podcast as well as your own health
now let's talk more about that jackpot
yeah this I watched the kid faint right
in front of me his head hit the pill
it's pretty great kids are [ __ ] faint
not yeah or you see that in weddings
like uh yeah they say don't lock your
feet when you're standing up for long
periods of time but I've never seen that
wait don't like you ever see your knees
don't lock your knees when you're
standing for a long time oh yeah I guess
like people just like at weddings yeah
like you see the groomsmen fall over and
pass hot they're drunk okay yeah but I
don't know why that that is dude you
guys the fact that people are fainting
at these shows it should be a marketing
point
yeah definitely I've I've never it
doesn't happen crazy every show it might
be like before this before I play the
vasectomy video I I routinely say before
this as a legal concern I have to tell
you with everyone in the room as a
witness that we are all here at our own
risk yeah and I explained that you know
we probably think you're [ __ ] kidding
I know but but yeah and I say it doesn't
happen all the time yeah but we average
one guy per show and I've come to learn
that if you are that guy you already
know you are that guy and that's like
one of the biggest laughs yeah yeah the
whole show like um yeah and the one
guy's sitting there like
they want to get like hot they want to
get like fresh air and go outside I'm
like do not go outside because like just
sit because you'll pass out in your seat
and you won't hit your head and then
you'll wake up and it's fine yeah and uh
they're like and then if someone doesn't
pass out during their [ __ ] then I feel
like a fraud when it happens I'm like oh
[ __ ] okay at least they know I'm yeah
and they're always like sitting down
with like an ice pack on the back of
their neck or like and I'd give them a
free bottle of hot sauce damn so yeah
dude we do need to make t-shirts I
passed out at a Steve ocean yeah we can
give them one but so so are you doing at
the skank Fest like you're gonna go up
and do yourself no no no no no no no
you're hosting it I'm gonna treat it
like I like when I hosted the Gathering
of the Juggalos
don't go nuts that'll be a hit you've
been to that I have not been to that
it's probably one of the coolest
experiences of my life I've heard it's
great dude it's really really cool man I
know I just [ __ ] killed it up on
stage really Kid and Play was there did
they like vanilla ice were they like
they love oh [ __ ] Vanilla Ice has
attended every single Gathering of the
Juggalos with like maybe a couple
exceptions for like the last 20 [ __ ]
years like he is straight Juggalo
[ __ ] it works with a guy he would he
would go to it every year yeah and I was
like you [ __ ] loser yeah and then he
would show me videos and I was like damn
that's [ __ ] good job dude I didn't
know much about it dude but but uh you
know I come out like like I was like
hosting the show his musical
performances so I come out I do like
whatever like you know do some silly
trick yeah some stun and then introduce
the band
and and so like I come out there they're
screaming like more than one person like
show us your butthole
that's weird you know and like like
going from like they're screaming like
shows your bottle and they're you know
they're like yeah they they love that
that's what they were the thing
and I was like well who am I to not
[ __ ] of course give them what they
want you know so I'd get out there and
if I can spread them wide and then it
was the musical act that oh
Project Pat
so who's your buddy on the Three Six
Mafia oh DJ Paul DJ Paul damn yeah
they're on [ __ ] jackass yeah DJ Paul
has a juggler tattoo on his neck I've
got one on my wrist
if you have that and you show up to like
prison like it's a gang affiliation I'm
just so mad that that I chose to get Jug
for Life instead of Jug's rule
like j-u-g-z rule like I get it yeah
it's a great sick dude yeah I mean jug
for life's pretty sick too but yeah I
got nervous like I looked up uh you know
the Juggalo tattoo yeah oh [ __ ] I
thought you were talking about going on
stage I've seen them like throw Faygo at
people or whatever
yeah that's terrifying they call it I
don't want anything to do with that
they're so those [ __ ] guys in ICP are
so talented at like [ __ ] rapping
while like
shaking up a bottle of Faygo and like
launch they make them into these [ __ ]
Torpedoes that go flying through 50
yards easy oh my God more than that
toes in it or something it's the most
visually [ __ ] stimulating thing where
the way they launched these two
different bottles of Faygo
but enough about it I digress enough
about that let's uh congrats on [ __ ]
getting on Rogan and oh thanks man how
many times you've been on Rogan see like
uh I think five or like five times this
year yeah I'm sure you haven't stopped
yeah it's just been this year
is there a connection that you put this
uh this YouTube special I mean you're
like the like the top of the Heap of the
YouTube comedy special yeah well I just
I didn't have a choice yeah I would have
liked it to be on Netflix that would
have been [ __ ] sweet but no I had to
do it myself like how many views is it
up to now the one in Austin should be
like six or seven million it's it's
great it has crossed seven million yeah
I usually check it over seven million oh
nice yeah the New Yorkers New Yorkers
yeah they were good to me yeah I was
worried about that they were they were
like we're gonna write an article about
you I was like dude I was gonna [ __ ]
kill me I'm doing an article with New
Yorker who's writing I don't know oh
okay I mean it never occurred to me to
be nervous about what someone's gonna
write about me when I do an article with
it turns out it's good yeah well I've
never because I I started with nothing
but negative press
That's how I was introduced was like
look at this piece of [ __ ] so anytime
like someone especially a publication
like the New Yorker yeah
you know from Stardom like you fell from
Grace yeah there are articles like the
opposite yeah it was nice from falling
down to Grace or something like that it
was yeah cool I don't like I don't like
the pressure though I liked the no the
fall was nice yeah it's like the fall
and then the rise and it's like well now
there's a it's gonna be a fall no you're
gonna fall dude
Jesus fell three times dude you're gonna
fall I'm gonna fall again
yeah you can always do the Legion of
skanks festivals every year true yeah
true yeah
yeah he's following him he fell a couple
times dude
didn't they have Ari shaffir on a lie
detector test and asked him if he
regretted like his his Kobe thing yeah
and he was like no I don't and he like
passed me like yeah yeah yeah dude
that's just a different kind of animal
dude he's wild I'm like way more
sensitive than you would imagine yeah
Stevo is like I could not no negative
press sucks yeah dude I'm super super
sensitive yeah Mark Normand we made when
we were talking to him about how you
were
coming on and he said that that you you
see set up be careful dude and Shane
does not like uh people suggesting that
uh that the cancer culture worked in
history oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
I I thought that that was kind of
interesting because I had
suggested and and apologies here for
going ahead and saying exactly oh no I
don't think I don't want to hear I get
it but uh yeah I get it yeah but I just
think it's I just think it's fascinating
but like my question was like is it it's
safe to to assume that there there have
been plenty of people who were bona fide
cast members on Saturday and Night Live
and just pretty quiet about it sure you
know like to really take off they were
just sort of like you know
um some people became big stars and and
a lot of people didn't and uh
for you like it but it was kind of a
launching deal like it was just like
everything yeah everybody it got eyes on
me for sure so there's that like I what
I what I've talked to Mark about is like
how it's annoying when like comedians
will be like I think it helped you and
it's like right bro like
maybe maybe but it might have helped if
I didn't get canceled and I was on SNL
like that could have been good right
that could have been maybe I could have
been good on there
um yeah but were you because you had to
probably work [ __ ] 10 times harder to
get that's the other thing is it's the
ego part of it where it's like no it's
not like I was just handed this yeah
getting canceled isn't a good thing
unless you do well afterwards yeah you
know what I mean and then it I don't
like to ever be in that position where I
gotta be like no I'm good like you know
what I mean I don't want to right let me
move on from that yeah whatever you know
apologies for again saying precisely
he's like now he also said he didn't
want to talk about your mother
how's she doing yeah she's still dead
but now he said that uh he said that
you've got a new sketch show oh yeah
yeah that's [ __ ] unbelievable uh we
just released it like an hour ago the no
trailer for it it's going to come out
October 4th so this is yeah it'll be up
so Gillian keeves dot TV yeah
gilliancieves dot TV we can put the link
in the video description of the YouTube
version of this oh nice so that's the
thing yeah after like
uh we just put out a bunch of sketches
for free last year and they people like
them so this time put them on to paywall
we got to make some money on it sure
yeah but yeah what's your approach to
the paywall uh we put on our website so
it's 9.99 you get all yeah you get all
the sketches I I was in a similar
situation with uh my second comedy
special everybody didn't want it and it
broke my heart because this was my first
uh multimedia deal not like uh like on
the road it was just me and a microphone
but in post-production I edited in
footage to illustrate the stories I was
telling in my state so it was this like
unique like multimedia comedy special
that like I [ __ ] to this day love
nobody bought it so I'm like all right
now I gotta [ __ ] put it out on my own
but the footage I cut into all these
stories is never allowed it's never
going to be loud and it was just
explicit [ __ ] my dick's all over it like
it's like
reality yeah obscenity ball stapling I
did get humped by an elk that was a
concern
um but uh
so I had to I'm sorry I had to figure
out
okay
but to figure out the paywall for us
what we did was we went to Louis CK's
website yeah and uh we got the same
people I believe that did that yeah yeah
we uh had like you know fairly amateur
tech people like uh somehow like look
under the hood of that website however
they did that yeah we just kind of put
it together I think we might be using
them I don't know Sky pilot oh no it's
like my pilot is like Vimeo and then Sky
pilot Bridges the Gap with like
connecting it to a paywall or something
like that okay
yeah but yeah like I did pretty well
with it man like uh it ended up not
being a loss
that's all you can hope for right yeah
this this one we'll see we put a lot of
money in it okay it could be a loss
all right but uh if um if if over seven
million views on a comedy special on on
YouTube is any indicator yeah I mean are
you active as hell on YouTube like
um no not really I mean I put up a
podcast once a week right yeah that's
about it I mean dude I I I I keep my uh
podcast on the podcast YouTube channel
and then that because um
like retention is such a big deal yeah I
feel like uh if we put the podcast if
people are gonna not go all the way to
the end I feel like it's gonna hurt the
the performance of other [ __ ] and the
algorithm and but then again the more
you
the more you post the consistency will
help you too so that's the thing because
we hired so there's like a production
team behind this and they hired a
marketing team
to promote the new sketches and the way
they're doing is they were clipping the
sketches from the first season that were
free and just kept reposting them and I
was like stop like you gotta like don't
oversaturate it just put it out when we
put it out like especially because it
looks like I'm the one doing it because
it's me it looks like I'm just reposting
myself over and over again on Instagram
like none of it was original it was just
the thing with like marketing and [ __ ]
like that it's like you pay a big
marketing firm to come in and like do
all that [ __ ] for you but you're like
dude I'm just gonna go on Rogan once and
yeah that's actually exactly what I said
I was like I'll just go keep going on
Rogan we'll do that yeah you know I mean
it's crazy because like uh all the money
that you have in like when you're
starting a business goes into the
marketing but it's like if you have a
huge following it's like I got that dude
it's all good right yeah especially if
it's yourself like dude I don't know
what my image exactly or whatever
however you want to say it but even like
we have like a hot sauce on Amazon it's
like if Steve does a post we go to
number one every time so it just keeps
going and it's like you know [ __ ] dude
major corporations would love to have
yeah something like that
yeah I mean
we
we do well when I promote the hard times
but still like the little hot sauce uh
Universe on Amazon like like our health
test doesn't make that much money yeah
no it's pretty good what's that
Community like I didn't want that I mean
whatever like the critical world of yeah
is like always in the top 20 but we
can't we can't Market it internally on
Amazon because of the word butthole
that's my hot sauce oh no it's called
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole so
we cannot advertise and like we're
losing out on so much [ __ ] money like
we came out with a new uh flavor of hot
sauce called Stevo's butthole Destroyer
no no
they're like we'll put them on the front
page of Amazon deal of the day but you
have to change the name it's like no
damn but if you go to Amazon you type in
the word butthole it takes you to our
hot sauce oh all right yeah I bet a lot
you guys are getting fifth graders
[Laughter]
is published for getting everybody to go
and plug in the word butthole on YouTube
yeah and it's a weird little like sub
Community because then people will do a
YouTube video of them chugging our hot
sauce and also like people start calling
everybody out and it's not even just
people chugging there's like people do
who there's there's like full-on hot
sauce review channels yeah they do
nothing but just reviews I was one of
those like the hot sauce Community like
stand up where they're like oh you think
you can just get into hot sauce yeah
because they [ __ ] about it yeah no
no you know who's a [ __ ] about it
was this one guy uh wouldn't pick up our
hot sauce I'm like dude we're like
number one on Amazon right now he's like
you use vinegar as a filler instead of
orange juice our people are gonna just
see right through that I'm like are they
you [ __ ] care are you sure dude I
like vinegar do we use vinegar as a
filler
yeah everybody does I mean Tabasco does
but like you know how you get some of
the hot sauce that are like really thick
and like a different color they use
orange juice instead
nobody [ __ ] cares I I actually do
care I like vinegar a lot yeah like I
just had vinegar on French fries this
weekend god dude I haven't done that in
a while it was great crucial balsamic
vinegar who doesn't like vinegar I just
bought these uh apple cider vinegar
gummies really dude take me to the
drugstore and I don't give a [ __ ] what
kind of gummy it is dude like that's
just like my excuse for eating candy
it's like vitamin gummies like vitamin C
gummies
I was taking huge dumps for sure it was
a victory because I'm like off sugar
like uh I can't eat like [ __ ]
re-season all that [ __ ] so I just like I
have a whole [ __ ] thing of gummies
dude
yeah vitamins did those emergency
gummies yeah those are nice those things
are dangerous
I love that [ __ ] are you putting gummies
in your mouth right now no that was a
nicotine that was nicotine you're just
swallowing yeah no it's not it's you're
supposed to it's not like dip oh really
yeah it's like it's not like it's like
not dip yeah oh it's like it's like a
nicotine gum yeah that's cool man so
yeah so you're you're trying to I just
try to quit I'm in public no I'll just
dip it home
because I was dipping it I was I kept
going to clubs I do spots during the
week in the city and like if you're
sitting there dipping these people they
don't like it I had a bunch of other
comedians are like yo that's [ __ ]
that's the grossest [ __ ] I've ever seen
yeah it's like all right yeah I had a
buddy that like we would go out drinking
he would like dip you know and drink
while he's yeah and then we woke up the
next morning we're all [ __ ] up and he
like
he's like god dude I slept with I hate
it when that happens
that when it happens like it happened
more than once in your life like just
had a dip in his mouth all night and
it's like that's crazy I dip and drink a
lot and I don't I've never done you dip
in some cigarettes at the same time I've
done that that's a sad that's a sad
moment let's face it
you're addicted to cigarettes dipping
nicotine of any kind then every day is a
sad day because people just look down on
you man with dipping and cigarettes like
they don't respect you and you stink and
you're miserable now I don't want to
sound holier than thou but gosh am I
grateful that I quit smoking cigarettes
and any form of nicotine and man do I
love helping people be freed of the
shackles of that addiction by letting
them know about fume products from
breathefume.com it's just natural
healthy stuff they give you this great
wooden inhaler that you put into uh the
wooden inhaler this core which is
infused with natural as essential oils
that come in all kinds of great flavors
that's actually proven to help with
cravings for nicotine and that's the
thing about cigarettes man is that it's
all just like hand them out like it's
like a fidgety busy work kind of a thing
and with this inhaler Mike it's not bad
for you it's gets you to just do all the
stuff that you're doing when you're
smoking plus it it's delicious I even
use it and I haven't had a cigarette in
14 years ma'am it's a great product and
you get 10 off your whole order if you
go to
breathefume.com Stevo that's b r e a t h
e f u
m.com slash Stevo for ten percent off
your your whole order and do if you're
sitting there thinking man I should
really do that because cigarettes and
nicotine like yeah yeah you really
should do that it's time to stop being
looked upon as a loser because you're
addicted to darn nicotine there I said
it breatheteam.com
Stevo and use the promo code Stevo and
break free of the shackles yeah nah
let's talk more about this with Shane
that's a real sad moment yeah that's too
much I had a roommate I remember I
remember
um meeting Bobcat Goldthwait and uh
he's he's a comedian yeah
he um
[ __ ] I think he he offered me a piece
of like Nicorette nicotine gum and I was
like oh no dude I'm cool yeah and then
uh
and and he says okay so then uh he
[ __ ] Pops in his own mouth he's
chewing it or whatever I said to him I
go no I'm not like uh I said what are
you trying to quit smoking he goes I
know I smoke too I just [ __ ] yeah
yeah
his whole deal was he'd choose nicotine
gum and smoke cigarettes
that's rad
yeah I got into like smoking cigars and
I was like I gotta quit and uh I went to
like the The Cigar Lounge I'm like I was
the last time I'm gonna be here I'm
gonna quit and the guy's like can I ask
you a question I was like yeah he's like
why why are you quitting oh yeah
because it's [ __ ] bad for you yeah
like that but it was like some people
just don't have that like you know yeah
I'm like [ __ ] this is gonna kill him
like I'm neurotic in your head every
time I do something so it's like he's
like he's like the germaphobe and sex
addict oh not a combo I'm a germaph
don't look at me like that dude
he's even doing spots in the the clubs
on Brett bigger touring too yeah yeah on
the weekends yeah yeah okay so I just I
did Boston and then I drove all the way
down to Philly on Sunday
no I was at uh laugh Boston Thursday
Friday Saturday and then they were like
do you want to open for Chris Rock in
Philly and I was like definitely so I
drove [ __ ] it was like seven and a
half hours yesterday that sucked just to
show up and you came did Philly and then
this morning I drove up here um [ __ ]
yeah my buddy Eric Andre was doing some
shows with Chris Rock and he said that
like
that it was so impressive Chris Rock
would have somebody record the show oh
yeah and then immediately after the show
that recording would be sent to like a
stenographer who would like type up a
script of the show yeah and then he'd be
pouring over the script of the show to
see where he could like eliminate words
yeah I mean it was it was crazy he had
yeah he had like bulletins of what he
was going to say I think he had it on
stage like so he could see his [ __ ]
because he went he did like an hour and
a half at least it's it's really [ __ ]
impressive and it was cool to watch like
it was just sitting backstage watching
Chris Rock I was like damn did you tell
that's as cool as it gets did you tell
them man I think that getting slapped
was the best thing yeah that's what I
said I said look I think it probably
helped honestly everybody told me not to
say this but yeah yeah but like don't
you think that like how how big was the
venue it was huge it was it was his
third night there yeah Auditorium yeah
but I didn't I didn't think it was going
to be as many black ladies
Chris Rock's crowd would be a lot of
honkies that's what I was anticipating
no I showed up to go on stage and I was
like oh I'm gonna bomb
they liked it yeah so how did uh the
invite get extended to you I don't know
it's just through my agents
that's Prince did he know that I mean
it's seven hour drive that's pretty well
I was yeah I was excited yeah so of
course yeah how long did you do uh like
15. yes quick 15.
man yeah it was cool there's no way that
like that he saw your schedule and it's
like oh well no I think he was just uh
yeah he's seen me at the cellar a bunch
and was like he's funny see if he wants
to do it I was like yeah definitely
you're talking backstage yeah we went
out and got dinner it was it was sick it
was awesome yeah yeah that's right and
then the next level is if you're gonna
do more than one night you're on his
private jet with them yeah I'll be sick
I just took one of those for the first
time me too where it was scary yeah I
don't like it yeah where'd you go I was
with Rogan and we went to the UFC two
months ago yeah two minutes yeah
yeah I wanted every podcast I go on I'm
like yeah me and Nate are a good friend
he's like dude what are you talking
about dude I saw you on the broadcast
like I said yeah this is my fat face the
closest
Gladiators are fighting I'm sitting
there eating [ __ ] chicken fingers
okay that's that's epic man yeah so you
you love watching the fights yeah yeah
especially next to [ __ ] Rogan and
them are sitting right here you're right
there and you're just it's terrifying I
mean it's truly terrifying the only
thing that sucks about going to see the
UFC fights in person is that you can't
hear the commentary I know Rogan and DC
and Anthony yeah dude they're so good
right but if you're sitting right next
to Rogan are you able to hear I can hear
the screams like if somebody gets hit
it's like oh but the whole crowd's
screaming too so right the you know what
I've done like is I'll be at the
Pay-Per-View event in the arena and I've
got my [ __ ] headphones and I'm
listening to the UFC fight pass but it's
like uh it's like an uh like a minute
and a half delay or something so I'm
hearing the commentary like I'm like a
minute and a half yeah yeah and I just
don't care because I love their
commentary so much yeah they they'll
tell you what the [ __ ] going on
because I'm sitting there like you have
no idea I can't tell if somebody blocked
it or if somebody just got kicked in the
head well yeah it's like a submission
attempt oh that's time yeah yeah yeah
he's got to lift the [ __ ] right arm
up or something yeah he's gonna do like
it's just so fascinating man I love it
dude yeah that shit's awesome the first
one I went to with him was in Gano
versus Cyril gone okay there's a
heavyweight champion Francis and Gano
from like me to you is the scariest dude
oh yeah you guys had him on the [ __ ]
thing yeah that's crazy
it was about what you would think it it
is like he's yeah it's not quite like
when you meet uh an NBA basketball
player and they're like so like you're
not prepared freaks dude like from what
you can watch basketball on TV until
you're blue in the face it nothing will
prepare you for me Shack or likes you
know like it's like wow it's not like
that when you meet in Connor but it's
more like what you would expect like
he's huge yeah he's terrifying yeah and
he's also the most soft-spoken nicest
guy like yeah that's even scarier right
it's like dude what's going on in there
yeah yeah it's kind of a [ __ ] though
yeah
[Music]
yeah and uh what's crazy too is that I
had no idea that they were gonna do like
so many different like super violent
things to Danger Aaron with the cup test
all I knew
because that was the first one of them
yeah so I'm on the set that day and
they're like oh dude Francis and Ghana
is coming to set today I'm like what
they're like what he's gonna punch
danger Aaron and the balls with the cup
I'm like dude I start campaigning like I
want because I'm such a fan I'm like I'm
like let me get the nutshot from Francis
and ganu and they were just like nah
dude like like this one's going to
Danger yeah and how [ __ ] up was it it
was like thank God he didn't like it
didn't just look like he was holding
back like he went for it yeah it was
great yeah and I ended up after seeing
how many different [ __ ] things they
did to Danger Aaron's balls like I'm so
glad that I got shut down when I asked
for that yeah couldn't be more thrilled
that I was not a part of that [ __ ] you
did the one though the the t-ball one I
did that I did the t-ball yeah he had no
cup that was that was that was brutal
but yeah man [ __ ] yeah that was uh
jackass I I went and I lived in Spain
for a while and when I went over what
was that that was it was after college
uh it was like 2014. I can't uh in
Madrid but it was uh I got I would get
on the train and everyone like I'd
always see jackass shirts oh yeah that's
great like you guys like jackass and
they're like oh yeah yakash
what was the purpose of going to live in
Madrid uh I went and I taught English
wow in Spain yeah that's cool English
I'm all right at it I'm okay in English
it was nice though you barely had to
speak Spanish so when did you start
doing comedy uh right before that and
then I left and that was one of the
reasons like I really wanted to do stand
up like I'd be I'd be in Madrid like
looking at Facebook seeing all these
guys from the Harrisburg Comedy Zone
which is where I was from like these
guys that sucked like getting the hosts
I'd be like these [ __ ] I should
be in there right and like I got home
and yeah focused on stand up entirely
that's good man yeah that little jealous
that [ __ ] Works sitting at home
especially when you're in another
country yeah yeah did negativity is
crucial like I don't think I got
anywhere in life based on like uh the
the joy of it I was like dude this
[ __ ] person called me a loser this
person
just like [ __ ] pissed off and and
vengeful success yeah it's the only way
and then you're never happy yeah it's
good anyway never want to be happy yeah
yeah I got a I I got this new book and
I'm like people ask me if I'm happy the
question just always made me
uncomfortable like because like I can
only react to the question just with
like a feeling and it's like no I'm not
[ __ ] happy like uh yeah and like who
the [ __ ] happy yeah and and what
wouldn't being happening accomplished no
right now
what would what would being happy
accomplish I'd be content I wouldn't
need anything more I'd be [ __ ] lazy
I'd be a loser yeah happy is for losers
I don't want to be a loser we're
extremely successful guys yeah there are
dudes like I think Rogan is happy I can
believe there's dudes that are happy
that are just driven psychos I need to I
Rely entirely on but what's the
motivating force behind like Rogan keep
doing what he's doing because like he's
already has it all like how do you keep
motivated like that every day how do you
sit in the [ __ ] ice bath for 25
minutes
I love burnt Crushers talking about uh
Rogan's whoop band how the whoop band
itself is like
yeah so at the end of the last podcast
we did with me normandari and Rogan we
started like longing beers and I drink a
lot and Rogan was like I can drink with
I can do that and I was like all right
and he was like no I'm gonna do just as
many as you like he got competitive we
probably can't psycho [ __ ] he got [ __ ]
up he was and you were fine he was
obliterated no I was drunk but he was
like
wow perfect falling down for bong and
beers huh but then he got back and then
he came back like two hours later we did
another show and he was yeah because he
probably [ __ ] took us up just like
took some type of it like did like a
[ __ ] three hours he did something so
you did this at the end of the podcast
and then you're going out to the concert
and then we went and did a show we did
Kill Tony right okay we did Tony himself
so me Norman and Ari show up and we're
hammered I'm hammering and then Rogan
shows up late and we're like there's no
way he's up and he was he was fine it
was crazy I mean I thought he was fine
at the time and then I rewatched it and
I was like damn he was hammered too I
was I was just [ __ ] pissed I was like
how are you okay he's like I'm fine
shankillas you're just kidding yeah he's
ready to go yeah it's so gnarly man I
talk about Rogan in my in my book and uh
I'm like
it's just kind of addressing how there
are certain people that were like not
down from you getting into stand up you
know and like one of those people and
and uh to his credit he was pretty just
candid about it was uh Mark Maron yeah I
went and I was promoting my first comedy
special on Marc maron's podcast and he
was like Hey dude I gotta say man you
know like I wasn't super thrilled about
you doing stand-up you know but like I I
you know I
it's like that there's just some people
who operate with the mentality of
scarcity like there's not enough to go
around yeah and like my theory is that
that Marc Maron felt that way because
because it's like if Stevo comes in and
succeeds during stand-up then that maybe
somehow takes food off of the table for
him yeah like maybe there's and maybe
I'm completely wrong about it but what I
really feel strongly about is that Rogan
it's like the the opposite yes the total
option he operates with a a philosophy
of abundance like there's just enough to
go around like he just wants there to be
more funny [ __ ] yeah you know he's like
I want my [ __ ] mailman to do [ __ ]
crazy I don't [ __ ] care like he's
funny but isn't that like if I had a
podcast that I started in 2014 and then
like Marc Maron started a podcast in
2020 I'd be like listen I wasn't really
happy with you coming onto the podcast
scene but you know now that you're here
it's like what's the [ __ ] difference
you know I think with comedy it's like
but the thing is he started in 08 versus
2012 yeah I mean I'm not talking about
marriage but of course but these people
that are like oh dude well I have like a
certain it's like why because that's all
you did After High School I guess with
stand up though Stand Up is like there's
only a certain amount of clubs it's not
like a podcast you can just throw it on
like stand and so when you're when
you're new like when I remember when I
was new headlining I couldn't sell
tickets and then Screech would show up
and they'd be like yeah you're off this
weekend Screech is here and be like all
right
first yeah Screech was selling wow more
than [ __ ] me yeah but like and then I
opened for him and he was a great guy he
was really [ __ ] nice yeah Screech was
cool was he doing like an hour-long set
yeah his [ __ ] was filthy too yeah he was
wild yeah probably really funny too yeah
it was funny
um yeah but my point was too with the
Marc Maron and Rogan thing was that like
I I acknowledge that my default like I'm
a Marin you know I'm like uh you know
like my initial thing is like no I don't
want you know I don't want anyone
[ __ ] stealing my Spotlight stealing
my bag [ __ ] yeah of course like my
and I I have to like with effort try to
have the the Rogan mentality and then
and I've over the years I've really been
more like uh but are you like that with
people doing stunts trying to help
people out for sure look at the way I've
just you know but you don't know but
you've never been like ah dude this guy
can't do it or like it's kind of weird
that this guy or have you always been
because like people are showing you like
when jackass came out everybody was me
and my friends right everybody started
making jackass like yeah
that's our thing I I admitted you had to
have seen it in uh in my book but the
last thing I did with Ryan Dunn was this
show minute to win it okay right where
we both went on it and I'm like yeah
this is like it's kind of a while back
like it was in 2011 and uh and I
admitted in my book that when when we
got called for that I was campaigning to
like have it be just me because I went I
felt like that like I'm a bigger star
like it'll be cooler like yeah if I'm
just you know I was trying to get done
kicked off oh that's crazy that's crazy
and and right when I say that I'm like
dude I understand that that that's a
[ __ ] shitheaded thing yeah it's just
true like I'm a [ __ ] you know like
that's how that's where I was at yeah
so yeah you were like that yeah 100 I'm
a Marin
yeah I'm a Marin dude and I'm working
hard to be more of a Rogan yeah it's
hard to be real good yeah that's it dead
it's it's tough man yeah I think that's
why it's so successful I can feel my
face is like red I'm embarrassed from
that no I don't know what happens it's
not red absolutely
but yeah you know your face gets hot
that guy's the worst yeah but uh but in
any case man yeah that's the covid
probably
I don't know is it weird when you take a
covid test like that you could start
feeling like psychosomatic symptoms like
oh I have it yeah I only ever feel like
I have covered if I'm being tested for
covert yeah
yeah for sure because it's the only time
I'm ever thinking about like whether I
feel right or not we landed in New York
yesterday and this guy on the [ __ ]
plane was like put his phone on was
talking out loud and his wife was like
she should be quiet but he was like
talking really loud and he's like yeah
Mom I was exposed okay like do you still
want me coming over or not and she was
like that's hilarious you know that's a
funny joke
he was [ __ ] dead guys where's the
cameras again no I was exposed they
don't know no one here cares
when you're telling this to Lux I'm
thinking that like oh wow some guy was
uh you know admitting to like showing
his wiener to uh yeah yeah I was exposed
yeah yeah Mom I pulled my leader mine
went yeah and then me and the lady
looked at each other next we're like is
this guy [ __ ] serious yeah I would
have been Maddie was talking on the
phone
plane shit's just really weird you saw
that guy punch the [ __ ] American
Airlines
like three days ago tried to go to the
bathroom in first class and they're like
you can't
and he swung he was like he had a lady
the flight attendant in the back of the
head it's the lady yeah and I thought it
was a dude I could be wrong
yeah they like zip tied them
another guy was like air-dropping porn
to like all the [ __ ] the pilot was
like dude can you whoever's doing this I
will turn the plane around now we'll
have like the whole you know please come
and check each phone and like some guy
was just airdropping porn to everybody
on the plane well they're the ones who
accepted it that's true I would have
accepted it takes two to [ __ ] air
drop
I thought you were looking for Tango I
was gonna be like Tango that's the
yeah
to complete an airdrop does take two
people that's true yeah dude so okay are
you doing spots in the city I'm not dude
I got a book my the book I've been
talking about yeah thank God I mean as
we're recording this comes out tomorrow
oh sick so I mean that's why I'm in New
York to to do the the whole what's it
about
it's your first book no it's my second
okay my first is a straight Memoir this
one is uh it's called A Hard kick in the
nuts what I've learned from a lifetime
of terrible decisions nice so it's sort
of a book of wisdom which uh serves as a
vehicle to
can tell all the crazy [ __ ] that
happened in the 10 years since my last
book came out did
you've had a good 10 years though it's
been pretty it's been pretty good yeah
no interest in being happy dude I choose
the hustle oh yeah yeah dude
um
okay so I want to talk more about these
sketch yeah this the sketch stuff and
and I'm kind of been I've been burning
up with curiosity when you say we put a
lot of money into it yeah like hot like
uh and it's it's like a season 78 000.
more like 147 around there okay when
when um like when people go to the
paywall and they're is it broken down
into like we filmed some episodes so
this one we filmed like a special we
filmed a live
showing of all the sketches with me and
John who's the he's the other guy was
there like a stage set for yeah yeah we
had like a couch and a chair and then we
would go we showed all the sketches like
kind of like a movie and then they
talked about a different sets so you can
have like different
what do you mean are there like
different sets like when you're in one
they can be setting up the other one no
no no we didn't do the sketch slot we
showed the sketch a lot like we we
filmed it and then aired it live okay
got it guys you know what I mean okay it
says it was more of a screening yes
screening that's what I'm looking for
right right right yeah it wasn't like
Saturday Night Live it wasn't right yeah
but we showed that we filmed that we
filmed the live show it's almost like
Chappelle Show where in between he comes
out and talks and then he shows a sketch
and then he talks okay
um so we filmed that we put that out and
then uh yeah I think on the website
you'll have the option you can watch
that or each sketch individually okay
yeah
um but but you're saying like we put it
out even though it comes out October 4th
so when this is out it will be out it'll
be out and uh and it's one hour long
thing or you can do it scheduled yeah or
you can watch it I think you can buy the
album or you can just get this the
tracks exactly exactly yeah I'm excited
about it I'm interested to see how it
goes right yeah and uh like the the cast
of The sketches yeah it's just me and my
friends from Philly okay yeah so uh our
dear friends from Philly have like a a
profile like a public profiler uh yeah
the comedians yeah yeah yeah this is not
rando's ride near coach yes
some there's a couple there's a couple
of guys in there but that's good yeah
yeah for sure yeah yeah you wanna
because I wrote their coattails too at
first yeah okay because I moved to
Philly and they were all established
blowing it in Madrid you had to come
back
hell yeah I was jealous yeah so you come
back from Madrid and these guys like let
you in the door that they opened yeah
exactly yeah exactly and then you did
laughs around those [ __ ]
yeah these are my friends the other
[ __ ] I hated the rest of those
[ __ ] all right okay
comedy scenes especially when you're
starting are so [ __ ] like Petty yeah
of course it never really stops but at
the lowest level everyone's no one's
happy they're just down the [ __ ]
everybody over there yeah even at the
late in the game you know yeah it's
still there but I mean it's a for sure
especially when you think about the like
the comedy club
like lifestyle like even for the
headliner yeah like to go do a weekend
at a comedy club you're you're [ __ ]
battling your way through the airport
and dealing with the airplane and
checking into the hotel and then you
can't even get a night's sleep because
you got to get up [ __ ] at like five
or six in the morning like to to get to
the radio station every radio station in
town yeah you've got to go to the comedy
club and do the same [ __ ] [ __ ] like
twice every night and uh it's it's
pretty gnarly yeah I go on when I would
go on the radio they'd be like oh thank
you so tell us about SNL what was
getting fired like I think it helped out
don't you think it helped don't you
think it helped you out wow I'd be like
yeah man that's 6 15 a.m yeah come see
me in Rochester yeah it's in a shed I
guess it did help it's a gnarly uh it's
it's a gnarly existence and then I
realized that to like to to [ __ ] about
that be like oh you know like how many
yeah how many Comics are there like
battling for for yeah just doing for
nothing you know I'd like the the MCS
the features of course begging for like
seven more minutes to open yeah it's
stage time yeah
so yeah man I I can see yeah it's tough
to complain especially people watching
this who have real [ __ ] jobs right
it's like I gotta wake up and go on the
news this sucks I got shows all night I
gotta wait I'm gonna drink I'm gonna
party again yeah
I get it dude but uh so I mean it kind
of makes sense that that comedy is like
like that yeah get it you could yell I
was when I was in open my car I was like
[ __ ] everybody I'd be like Rogan's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] him yeah and you meet him
like sir I'm so sorry I was a coward did
you say that I mean I don't know if I
talk [ __ ] on road I'm sure I talk [ __ ]
on just about everybody right yeah and
then you meet them in person you're like
damn I'm an idiot
well you just don't realize how hard it
takes to get to that spot of course I
remember there was a comedian whose
Netflix special I thought sucked and I
said it I was on a podcast I was like
that [ __ ] sucked and then I went and I
did a show with him I just happened to
do a show with him that night in New
York and he murdered and I followed him
and I was like damn that guy was good I
gotta shut the [ __ ] up but he killed and
I was like all right I see yeah I gotta
shut up yeah yeah generally like if if
you don't have something nice to say I
think that's the way to go yeah but when
you like when I started I was like no
one's ever gonna hear this I'm not going
to be a headliner I'm just talking [ __ ]
and then you get there and you're like I
shouldn't have said all that yeah
whatever that happens but dude like and
it's good to you know to acknowledge
that yeah
it's like Bully beat down you remember
that show and like the bullies would be
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] guy and the UFC
fighter comes in and just murks him you
know like it's like a couple photos no I
still would if I was bullying a guy in a
UFC guy beat me up I'd be like you're
still a [ __ ] dude I'm gonna [ __ ] you up
for this you just embarrassed the [ __ ]
out of me yeah dude I had uh I I had
this um this funny ass chick open for me
recently in Ottawa and she had a bit
about she's she says uh God I can't
believe they're still bullying it's so
dangerous with all the guns
it's not worth it it's not worth it
too many guns in the schools like a
great bit yeah that was the I was I was
thinking about last night because I was
with Chris Rock it was that was one of
the first bits that I was like damn I
was in like fifth grade Listen to I
think it's on Bigger and Blacker and
it's a joke about Columbine and he's
like they were gang of loners they had
there was like six of them together and
they were he was like they had six
friends there were six of these he's
like I haven't had six friends my entire
life what are these buckets
laughs
yeah that was wild I [ __ ] that joke up
you got a funny looking dog dude yeah
dude she's looking for more places to
vomit I mean I've never seen her like
this before
she probably drink some of your [ __ ]
dip yeah I don't know I wonder like uh
we we should maybe give give her some
attention
um do you sell any uh merch or anything
like uh podcast we sell podcast merch
but no not at shows okay and where do
people get your uh uh I think Gillian
keeves now has merch and a man chain
secret podcast they sell we sell shirts
yeah okay and what's the website I think
it's Ms secret pod.com cool just Google
Google Matt and Shane secret podcast it
is there one website that's like a hub
for everything where you can get the pay
whatever oh yeah Gillian cubes that
merch is there with the show so that's
what we want to put in the video yes.tv
Gilly and keeves Dot TV yes all right so
I can get everybody to watch this sketch
comic yeah hopefully it's good the way
that Mark Norman described it he was
like that the irony is they've if I can
fire them from us now in the sketches
he's doing on his own are way [ __ ]
funny yeah that's nice that's nice of
him to say so you're going to war with
Lauren Michaels yeah definitely [ __ ]
that [ __ ] no he's the man yeah
he's a good dude yeah I believe it he
was a good dude the whole time cool yeah
I was surprised by that yeah I think
people are surprised to hear that
they're like he's got to be a piece of
[ __ ] it's like no dude he's happy thanks
so I've never gotten the vibe I got a
call last week from I guess the New York
Post is writing an article about him and
interviewing people that worked there
and they called me and they were like
she was trying to get me to say
something about Lauren Michaels and I
was like no he's a good I got nothing
and she was like yeah every single
person I've called has said that yeah
it's crazy I get that I just watched a
uh Vice hour-long show called The Dark
Side of comedy and I watched the episode
about Chris Farley yeah it's a talk and
like it's a tough one but uh like
just from that I didn't like that I
can't imagine that anybody would ever
have anything bad to say about Lauren
yeah that's what who else was on that
show The Dark Side of Comedy oh I'm not
sure oh they have did they have a
Roseanne I think or something I don't
know no I don't know it was hers I guess
it was I think that tweet was pretty
dark
yeah I can't remember because I only
watched that one not that I was like
disinterested in the other ones that's
the one that popped up you could make a
dark side comedy about probably every
comedian yeah or any person yeah of
course right but yeah most comedians are
it usually ends poorly yeah yeah we're
not happy people yeah it usually ends
pretty sad well Mark Norman's a [ __ ]
funny Mother he is he's a man like we
were impressed by him and uh his vote
that you know I don't get nothing
nothing to nothing to prove nothing to
gain he vouches for your schedule oh
nice good so everybody yeah goddamn over
there and [ __ ] watch that [ __ ] right
now
yeah thanks bro cool man and uh anything
else that we can promote for you no
that's all that's all all right let's
get that [ __ ] mind back oh yeah dude
go go go watch how [ __ ] intense the
production value is true quarter million
easy check that out the production value
is too hot yeah it's too hot
yeah all right brother hey dude means a
lot thank you
could Shane Gillis be any more likable
man what a cool dude and of course his
uh new project is now available and as
promised the YouTube Watchers can go
right into the description of this
YouTube video and click the link to
support Shane Gillis and uh what else
can I say man I've had an intense
grueling week of uh of promoting this
book
um
[ __ ] it's it's been really really
intense and draining and uh we're super
struggling with Amazon but uh uh I don't
even want to get into that let's just
focus on how cute Wendy is and thank you
so
[Music]